hey guys we are back with another
episode of steampunks the show where we
go through all of the latest releases
over the last week on Steam and let you
know what's good my name is Jess
McDonald and I'm Edmund Tran and without
further ado let's talk about what's
worth talking about what's your first
game alright my first game is called
city of brass the city of brass is a
first-person roguelike dungeon crawler
set in an Arabian Nights world so it's
made by an Australian studio good
uppercut games who are comprised of a
bunch of people who actually worked on
Bioshock 1 and 2 okay so the best part
about this game is the combat system
there are a bunch of different weapons
you can use but the core of everything
is your whip and this whip can be used
to do a bunch of things so you can whip
an enemies legs to trip them up smack
them in the head to stun them and you
can whip their weapons to disarm them
the whip can also be used to grab the
objects to throw at enemies and then you
have the sword which works about as
you'd expect
so whipping dudes trip them up and then
fishing with your sword is very
satisfying to do in this game it's like
any good Indiana Jones style adventure
there are spikes and arrow traps all
over the place as well as sort of
crushing rocks and stuff like that and a
big part of the game is making sure you
recognize these and avoid them as part
of your run-through but you can also use
them to your advantage so during a fight
you can kite someone to a location then
trip them up when they're over a spike
bit and let them get annihilated by
spikes there's quite a variety of
different enemy types and sort of each
one needs different strategies to
overcome as it's all roguelikes
levels are procedural and death is
permanent so you'll need to work a lot
on your sort of combat skills but that's
okay because combats really satisfying
to learn and being good at it comes with
its own rewards yeah mental rewards but
in terms of sort of actual digital
rewards that you get in the game you can
use the treasury collect along the way
to purchase upgraded weapons they come
with like status effects and the
difficulty curve is actually pretty
gradual because of this cuz you'll do
more damage and all that kind of stuff I
think this game looks really nice too
the Arabian Nights thing is certainly a
theme you don't see a lot of these days
I mean there are some kings in this game
for sure but for me the weapons sword
combat is so fun and so strangely unique
know that it's worth checking out it's
25 bucks on Steam and it's also
available for Xbox one and ps4
sweeeeet well that one sounds pretty
pretty easy to sum up um what's not easy
to sum up is a massive game that came
out this week on PC Total War saga
Thrones of Britannia I am a total war
fan from about 15 years ago and boy is
it hard to get back into total war
there's a lot that's happened at that
time so in this particular game as you
can imagine you're playing out sort of
the evolution of the British Isles when
there are a lot of different factions
and you're choosing one and basically
conquering Britain it's historical in
the way that there are the factions that
are around at the time so we're talking
west axis the gales the Vikings you name
it this I think about twenty of them so
you're still gonna have historically
accurate factions historically accurate
Terps and figures but of course you
can't expect any historical battles here
because you're recreating an invented
version of history so as much as this is
obviously a total war game it is as I
mentioned the saga title it's smaller
scale so certain things have been
stroked back different things have been
changed which is sort of dividing total
war fans as to how they feel about this
one but as I said it was designed to be
a standalone spin-off title and it does
come at the lower price point of $45 as
a result of that so one of the things
has changed is with settlements you'll
now have minor settlements that can be
captured and can't be garrisoned so that
means defending your area is a more
tense endeavor since people can come
from anywhere and just take your
undefended settlements and you need
those settlements to do things like
sustain farms or mines or whatever their
predetermined to be supplying resource
wise on the flipside it also means you
can take settlements from your foes to
starve them out push them into attrition
and things like that
another interesting thing this time
around is that you can hire troops from
a universal garrison in this game but
they take time to come to full power so
you can hire troops from any of your
even minor settlements but they weren't
arrived in their full force so that kind
of simulates the idea of troops arriving
to the army gradually if you're new to
the series or it's been a while this is
going to be a ton to take in there is no
very obvious
Oriol which can be rough if this is
either your first endeavor into total
war or the first time you played it in a
really long time the complicated nature
of this game is as I see it an upside as
much as it is a downside because when
you do get embedded in the game as you'd
expect with all games that are hardcore
strategy it is deep as hell and there
are so much to micromanage your generals
for all your different settlements have
various attributes that impact their
effectiveness how good they are at being
generals and give you little buffs to
things like your resources or armies
combat is the main thing that you'll
find to be very familiar if you've
played any turtle war game before
they're varying on scale from little
skirmishes and fields to huge castle
assaults and the tradition of total war
the animations are still pretty janky
that said the area map looks excellent
there are short-term and long-term
victories ranging from all-out
decimation to raising your fame level or
holding certain cities as someone who
loves strategy games but isn't a total
war devotee I think this is a really
cool installment I love the area of
history I think the saga thing is a
really good idea and this in clever
additions if you're already a total
player that looks to be enough here to
revitalize the franchise without it
feeling completely different from
everything that's come before
[Applause]
alright well that game was all about
surviving in ye olde England the next
time I played is about surviving in the
forest creepy in a game called the
forest so this is a first-person open
world survival game that just came out
of early access it went into early
access in 2013 there's a long time ago
so the premise is that you're a father
who's travelling with his son on a plane
playing crashes in the wilderness and
your son gets kidnapped by a cannibal
dude and you have to survive there are
no real goals in this game there are
some survival guidelines that are
suggested but other than that how you go
about progressing is 100% up to you much
like other survival games you'll start
chopping [ __ ] down and gathering
materials to make sure you can stay
hydrated fed and warm there's weather to
think about there's animals to hunt and
there's a day/night cycle to worry about
too but it gets really dark I'm not a
hardcore survival sim player but I think
the lip of these games is really really
easy to get sucked into view let
yourself of course it wouldn't be a true
PC survival game without some
adversaries and like I said before this
island is littered with these absolutely
terrifying looking skinless cannibals
who can go absolutely ape [ __ ] and come
at you if they spot you well sometimes
not it's all about avoiding the
cannibals when you can see them instead
of gearing up to take them on when you
need to
tikkun build weapons like advance spears
and bows and arrows and all that kind of
stuff I think one of the mysteries of
the forest is sort of what's the deal
these cannibals and are they like a
society or are you the real monster and
all that kind of stuff there was a point
where I got captured and got strung up
and encountered some pretty disturbing
are scenes so this is as much of a
little bit of a horror game as much as
it is a survival game but there is the
option to have a peaceful mode without
enemies which is really great if all you
want to do is chill and build some log
cabins now when this game first came out
in early access I remember speaking it
looked [ __ ] stunning and it still
looks pretty good five years later it's
definitely got a focus on being
realistic and it has some nice sort of
models and post-processing effects I
think the realistic vibe of the forest
makes it a little more appealing to me
as a survival simulation cuz it gives
you this really cinematic feel and tone
that makes it feel like you're playing a
video game version of lost thing there's
also a co-op mode which I haven't
personally tried but I've seen a bunch
of great videos on Twitter of people
getting up to some cob
and looks like it could be a ton of fun
and it's also very reasonably priced
it's only 20 bucks on Steam which makes
a really easy recommendation even if
you're only a little bit interested in
survival games whether that's peaceful
survival games with 10 survival games
so check out in the forest alright so
cannibals pretty scary but uh so is high
school and yeah I know I could've got a
monster angle I went with high school so
I'm talking about a game that actually
all of us in the game so Australia
office played this week called months to
prom
sir prom is coming up in three weeks I
believe and basically you want to kind
of get in the good graces of whoever you
a prom prospect is by doing things they
want being the kind of person they want
and then hopefully they end they won't
rebuff you you'll be answering a bunch
of questions which determine your
starting stats but these stats are a
little unusual so they include things
like fun baldness smarts and money so
you'll have the opportunity in the
morning afternoon and evening to decide
where to go on the school grounds each
day one of those places will generally
reward you quite reliably with a certain
stat and then the second half of that
period will consist of you confronting
one or more of the cool kids
aka your potential prom dates in school
that you're trying to date so if you
play the York this game will look and
feel really familiar I would say it's
like a very adult silly and occasionally
super confronting version of that game
so since the stats are things like fun
it can be tricky to figure out which
answer in any situation that arises
associates with which start it's a lot
more obtuse as to which answers
associate with things like fun or
boldness or money I will say upfront
that I think we all found the prom date
prospects pretty universally hateful but
look they're monsters part of the whole
shtick your monsters they're monsters
which also plays into the complete
absurdity of events which are almost
always related to killing people or
drugs or sex so kids playing this game
this game also beautiful art I really
love the images
so far I mean a big part of this game is
the writing right yeah it's really
humorous and meta it can be hit or miss
sometimes it's humor that I think it
provided more sort of cringes and laughs
which is a good thing especially for a
competitive co-op party game like this
it is weirdly fun to play with friends
so it's exactly the same game if you
played on your own but it's sort of like
a screen share you just get to watch
everybody else go about their turns
there's thirteen hundred and eighty four
different outcomes two different
scenarios twenty two endings and 388
unique events this game is also 12 bucks
so you're really not spending too much
if you like the sound of it it's pretty
much exactly what you think you're
getting except probably slightly vulgar
to itis so if you're on board with that
you'll probably have a fun time with
this
[Music]
all right that does it for this episode
of steampunks if you played in the games
we play this week and you're something
to say about them let us know at our
Twitter account I'm at at Minh Tran I'm
at just McDonald well you can also let
us know if you think we should look pay
attention to a few future games on Steam
but until next week we'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]